in the opening scene we see a
middle-aged woman in a dimly lit parking
lot she appears to be scared and
frantically looks around the place after
a while she gets a text on her phone
which makes her even more nervous she
then hides her car keys inside one of
the rear tires before fleeing the scene
following this we are introduced to our
protagonist Kenny a 19-year-old boy who
lives a mundane life he lives with his
mother and younger sister and works at a
restaurant as a waiter Kenny appears to
be a kind-hearted and gentle boy who
likes helping people at his workplace he
is loved by everyone even the customers
are impressed by his selflessness and
kind nature in one instance Kenny
returns a little girl's toy and greets
her goodbye the latter smiles back and
happily leaves wait what one day Kenny
returns home to find his laptop missing
on looking around he discovers that his
sister has been using it enraged he
quickly takes it away from her and
scolds her it's almost as if he is
hiding something illicit in that laptop
after a while Kenny returns to his room
and tries to surf the Internet however
to his dismay he learns that his laptop
has caught a virus he desperately tries
to remove it but to no avail when
nothing else Works Kenny downloads an
antimalware software from an illegal
site as soon as he installs it the virus
is deleted from his laptop but
unbeknownst to him the webcam also
mysteriously turns on indicating that
someone is watching him later that night
Kenny locks his room and starts
pleasuring himself he Scrolls through
numerous websites for good content but
while doing so he suddenly receives an
email from an unknown person the message
reads we saw what you did for you see
Kenny was Googling OverWatch there is
also a video attached in the email and
when Kenny opens it he is shocked to the
core the unknown person is apparently
hacked his laptop and recorded him
pleasuring himself before Kenny can even
understand what's happening another
another email pops up this one
blackmails him to send his mobile number
or else his video will be leaked online
scared Kenny has no choice but to oblige
after a while he receives a text on his
phone which asks him to always keep his
location services on and to keep his
phone charged the sender also mentions
that Kenny will be activated when the
time comes desperate our boy tries to
offer the person money but the latter
only replies with tell no one for the
next few days Kenny doesn't receive any
messages yet he feels dejected at home
he barely talks to his family and often
locks himself in his room probably to
Google OverWatch again things aren't
better at his workplace either the once
charming and energetic Kenny is now a
shadow of himself he is always silent
and absent-minded which prompts the
manager to often scold him a week later
Kenny's worst fears come true as the
unknown person finally messages him he
sends a location asking Kenny to reach
their before 12:00 p.m. failing to do so
will result in the leak of his video
terrified Kenny immediately takes a sick
Le and rushes to the SLE location on his
bicycle on reaching there he finds no
one so he lets the sender know that he
has arrived in response the ladder asks
him to wait then a few minutes later a
guy arrives on a scooter without saying
anything he hands Kenny a package and
clicks a photo of him as the guy sends
the picture to someone Kenny realizes
that he too is being forced to run
errands you Google OverWatch too yeah
this means that the hacker is
blackmailing numerous people right now
after the guy departs Kenny receives
another location on his phone along with
a room number the hacker then asks him
to deliver the package there Kenny is a
bit scared about this but he has no
choice but to comply along the way he
Peaks into the package and discovers
that it is a cake in the next scene
Kenny reaches the said room and knocks
on the door but no one opens he then
mentions that he has brought a package
but still the same outcome just then the
hacker suggests that he use a certain
Mindy's name as soon as Kenny does so a
man named Hector nervously opens the
door it turns out that he is also being
blackmailed by the hacker Hector angrily
asks what's going on to which Kenny
reveals that he has been sent here by an
unknown person when Hector grabs his
phone and reads through the messages he
learns that the boy has also been
victimized their conversation is
suddenly interrupted when the hacker
texts Hector he says that the two will
now have to team up and deliver the
package to a specified location there is
a car in the parking lot which they can
use for this Mission it is then revealed
that this is the same car which the
woman had left in the opening scene
later as Kenny and Hector drive to the
specified location they ask each other
about their misdeeds Kenny says that he
was watching some videos and pleasuring
himself when the hacker recorded him now
they are threatening to release the
video to the internet if he doesn't
comply after this Hector reveals that he
is a married man with a daughter he
loves his family a lot and there is no
problem with his marriage however one
night when he was drunk he ordered an
escort online her name was Mindy as
Hector was chatting with her he sent his
elicit images In the Heat of the Moment
this is when the hacker recorded their
messages and started blackmailing him
Hector fears that if his wife knows
about this she will divorce him and take
custody of his daughter hearing all this
Kenny freaks out and begins crying but
Hector assures him that everything will
be all right he is confident that after
they finish their errands they will be
let free after a while they arrive at
the specified location the hacker then
texts them mentioning that there are
some objects inside the cake which they
will have to retrieve on checking the
duo finds a pair of sunglasses a cap and
a gun this scares the two and they
wonder why they need a gun just then the
hacker sends them another another
message dress up like the OverWatch
characters he asks who would like to be
the driver and who the robber Hector and
Kenny just stare at each other in
disbelief and soon they realize that
they are outside a bank Panic sets in
and they contemplate abandoning the
mission but then it Dawns on Hector that
his family is on the line so he
confidently says that he is going to be
the driver Kenny is still not ready to
proceed with the mission but after
Hector explains about the consequences
if his video is released he reluctantly
agrees Kenny then puts on the sunglasses
and cap grabs the gun and heads inside
the bank he immediately points his gun
at the cashier and demands that she hand
over all the money she has while doing
so Kenny becomes so scared that he pees
in his pants but fortunately none of the
bank employees resist and they give up
all their money without any problem
after this Kenny rushes out of the bank
and gets inside the car Hector then
speeds the vehicle away concluding their
mission on a successful note shortly
after they receive a text from the
hacker saying they have one final task
he has sent a location where they should
proceed now the duo arrives there and
finds that it is an isolated place with
a forest in the distance Hector then
receives another text in which he is
instructed to destroy the car as for
Kenny he is asked to take the money bag
and head inside the forest the hacker
promises that this is their last mission
and after this they will be free
following this the duo bids each other
goodbye and sets off in their respective
directions when Kenny arrives in the
forest he sees a man waiting for him
there is a large parcel nearby as well
seeing this Kenny believes that the man
is the same hacker who has been
blackmailing him but before he can
confront him the man discloses that he
has been ordered to open the package and
turn on the device the device is
actually a drone with this Kenny
realizes that the man is another victim
as the two stare at each other in fear
and disbelief the man asks are you ready
Kenny doesn't understand what's going on
so the man explains that they will have
to fight the winner will be rewarded
with the cash hearing this Kenny becomes
nervous and he asks who will determine
the winner at the same time the hacker
texts him fight to death this means that
the last man standing will be declared
the winner terrified Kenny brings out
his gun and points it at the man when he
can't do it he points it at himself
however when he pulls P the trigger he
realizes that the gun was always empty
taking advantage of this distraction the
man lunges at Kenny and the fight
officially begins on the other hand as
Hector reaches home he receives a
Trollface picture from the hacker and as
he enters his wife's room he finds her
crying it turns out that despite
finishing all of the tasks the hacker
still disclosed his affair to his wife
haor is Shattered by the Revelation and
he has no words to say elsewhere we are
shown the same woman from the first
scene just like Hector she also receives
a troll face on her phone indicating
that her secret has been leaked when the
woman nervously turns on her computer
she discovers that her racist Outburst
has been spread across the news dooming
her the scooter guy fate is also the
same whatever Scandal he was hiding has
been disclosed and his family is
swarming him for answers finally we are
taken back to Kenny who appears to have
won the fight he is bloodied and
battered but at least he has the money
with him unfortunately as he staggers
his way back home he receives the troll
face on his phone then his mom calls him
unpicking up she sobbingly asks if he
was watching illegal child videos this
shockingly reveals that Kenny is a
pedophile who is pleasuring himself to
elicit content as his mom continues
crying on the phone he doesn't say a
word and simply hangs up in the final
scene as radio head's exit music blares
on why are we mentioning that
some police officers arrive and arrest
Kenny he doesn't resist nor does he
speak I think I speak for all of us when
I say You Kenny subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching